oh my god
oh hi I hope this is what are you doing
here I hope neither of us are peeking
and everything looks good
very slipshod setup compared to what we
had in San Francisco I'm in New York
you're in Portland yeah we're like on
different coasts the show must go on the
show must go on
um we were lucky enough to have
resonable to remake code in advance I
have played a lot of this game I don't
think you've played it at all Yeah right
have you played the demo or not while
you played in 83 when we do the
subscreen fresh but this is fan art from
our friend David J Hart part of it
behind the screens we're gonna start
putting fan up during fan art during the
intro but yes your continuing resident
Knievel as a lot of people have hoped
and suspected it might take a little bit
there might be a few kinks that we need
to iron out but we are doing it remotely
the giant bomb people were as you can
see from the Beast cast thing they were
kind enough to let me use their studio
for lighting everything but I believe
you broke into giant bomb just because
you didn't have a computer I need to fix
that I pick up the lock
couldn't you broke and broken in a
stolen one of their mics I could have
yeah under here you're skyping in to me
right now I'm running most of the
software on my end and I'm playing on a
ps4 I'm gonna switch to the PIP yeah a
lot of what you guys are seeing is the
first time I've ever tested this so if
you guys have feedback for us like the
bitrate is too low or you know the mics
are peaking let me know because I'm kind
of I'm kind of dealing with that stuff
as we go here and I'm listening to the
recordings and learning and making
changes to them but I'm kind of doing it
all based on just what I see and what I
hear also like trying not to have file
sizes that are like 15 gigs so we're
gonna test this and hope that it goes
well today and if it doesn't we'll just
try again okay
yes and this is the first time I think
the last time we played a game that came
out this recently was resonable seven
this is the first time so if you're
watching this it'll go up like the day
after this game comes out we didn't
wanna put it up on day of even though we
could have yeah and we didn't we didn't
want to put it up on the last Tuesday
which is when review embargoes go up
because we wanted to give people namely
can evil viewers time to play it
themselves but we're gonna continue on
as if it's a normal season and continue
the show now that we're doing it
remotely yeah it's a good template to to
make sure that this actually works in
itself right because maybe like there's
really not a huge problem with you
yelling at me through headphones while I
play the game and if that's the case we
can just keep doing these things did you
want me to play as Leon or Claire I
think a few people had said let's do
Claire first cuz we did Leon during our
resident to play through okay this is
gonna be funny cuz my my camera is on
this screen but I'm playing on this
screen so when I'm playing it's gonna
kind of look like I'm looking at you oh
cool hi so that's how I'm gonna play all
day I had like beat it
what is the time of this recording I've
beaten Leon's campaign in this game oh
my so sorry sorry started Clarence but I
do Claire okay imma no we did we still
owe the people a Claire B scenario at
some point in the future if we can keep
it for anybody I always do Claire okay
I'm gonna start it right now and then
I'm just gonna double check audio
hopefully everybody waiting wait wait
wait wait how much do you remember
resonable - like fairly well I remember
certain aspects of it I remember like
remember how you liked me yeah I
remember liking it a lot I remember they
had really good jump scares of like um
the liqueurs I remember that I remember
dog jump scares I think I get like
muddled with like how it ends yeah yeah
but I remember its puzzly and good so
okay that should be good
yeah that's I was curious what you
remember but okay
Oh assisted standard or hardcore prolly
standards a standard okay but still
pretty tough is it okay
ammo is scarce that makes me nervous all
right well I'm just gonna be double
checking doctor resonable zero you can
get through this oh god I hope so
can you hear it
I barely had buzz on I know that game oh
I bet you the game plays too
I'm gonna leave it up for the oh how
[ __ ] whoa could it be if he's like
sounds like my husband that's how that's
how we elevate
it's a huge hamburger definitely hit her
check her pulse
he's about here
just like my wife
[Laughter]
behind you I'm into it
these cutscenes are different right oh
yeah like they've got of openings and
stuff cuz I don't remember that at all
it's I don't know it's funny like you'll
start to see you they were super
faithful to some of this game but they
were also super like they branch off
from the original as well I'm just kind
of like altering the game audio right
now to around negative 45 and I hope
that's low enough and if it's not then
oh you're playing okay so I'm playing
and yeah I think the game audio should
be good if it's not we'll find out
unfortunately I am not hearing what OBS
hears I'm hearing what I hear run that's
important oh my god that's my run yeah
that's not running that's how I like
walk fast with my dog when it's about to
rain
that's not Dom B run her jackets sick in
this game though it's so shiny you'll
probably like this you kind of noticed
that X right there it's like the
resonable 7ui
design in general her character looks
really good yeah very um
your gameplay audios fine I'm assuming
because I'm its move I can barely hear
is it low for you I can turn it up yeah
it's fine it's yeah is that better
I don't know I can't hear what you do
anything yeah you're right she's not
doing anything yeah that's better
it's low for me too if that helps
because I don't want it to feedback on
my mic but like I said yeah as of our
next recording I'll have new hardware
and that should fix that problem it has
been a little bit of a logistical
nightmare getting this together I didn't
think it was gonna be this hard but the
problem is is sending you my voice and
your voice oh yeah oh honey want to
start well that guy is like the Dave
Matthews Band logo has been bit do I
have a gun feel like I shouldn't be
checking anything out without a gun I
hold out I'll - oh you can't yet mm-hmm
this is not no you don't of course of
course he thought he did hahaha this
game is really gory was like beef jerky
came off his spine okay kill him I
missed a miss I missed amidst its good
start shut up oh oh so uh tip if you
hold l2 and wait if you stand still you
could yes see the reticle like yeah it
does that you're much more accurate so
you can shoot him while you're moving
but it's like better if you are standing
still yeah
jeez Oh
stay down I don't have a lot of bullets
yeah I have three bullets left see at
the beginning of resonable to the
original you're going through that like
gun shop remember you meet Tony who's
got the shotgun he's like hey what do
you do any points at you and then he
gets overrun okay so this is like pretty
new
oh so it's this is like the new system
that's your okay so I can't open this
door yet
correct
the music it's so scary is there bullets
in here cuz that would be awesome yeah
weird gas station okay cool that's the
key I opened my inventory with triangle
that's important no I [ __ ] shot him
you were there you all thought gee so
one thing I didn't like about resonable
six is that when you hit the zombies
yeah you couldn't really there was no
reaction on their part right the thing
that made for good is you could shoot
them in the lag you can see them
reacting this game is very good about
wherever you hit them like you feel like
there's less force behind your bullets
yeah yeah whoo that felt nice yeah I
appreciate how chunky that sounded yes
no I don't know I do not have the
bullets to deal with this get out get
out of there where is he on the front
door oh [ __ ] oh my god I can't believe
you got out of that thank you
compliment go door check on
oh [ __ ] Leo it's really cool in this
game colleges
Oh load house she didn't do that with
two bullets you guys know I really like
you have like the 38 snubnose when he
plays Leon yeah you get throw like the
little the Mathilda he became something
I don't know they're different it's my
point I see
oh my goodness alright if this is a
cutscene I can turn it up yeah wait
you're a cop
you got to tell me if you're a cop oh
you're not this just does a line off huh
oh you are just like acting in this game
is really good and I like having played
the whole game I didn't say that is the
case um I remember in the in the demo
that we played feeling really satisfied
with the with the acting and just that
mysterion general it just felt really
genuinely authentic to me
yeah you met Marvin
[Music]
party's been canceled guy he doesn't say
it his team he doesn't he doesn't say
what does he say just says like well
you'll see work yeah I know I I won't
spoil I ate your cake it was poisoned
spectra city looks way bigger in this
than I thought it would be but yeah it's
kinda like a game of Thrones West world
intro um that's the intro of Sin City oh
right yeah I'm turning it down oh wait
no that's gonna be another cutscene
turning it back up boys this part should
feel familiar to you yeah stations not
much bother you'll know something
yeah but what if we're the only ones
well there's no survivors they're
survivors it's a big city there has to
be
they take a photo I'm taking a photo of
my trash set up wait let me take it from
my perspective because you have no idea
how many [ __ ] cables my cable setup
is trash I'm gonna wait until we make
sure this episode is working before I
tweet it though it's a look it's a
goddamn nightmare am I allowed to tweet
any like of these images like of the
guys probably not I have to play it not
yet I have to turn down the gameplay
oh hey as he's dying and of amber a
flame it's like it reminds me of my wife
my wife it's a good joke feel like I
should want a political correctness
[Laughter]
okay so there's gas leaking yeah that's
bad out of his car - or their card like
their cartoon that's what exactly that I
would have said oh but I was like
mission impossible
do you remember that yes I do delivered
written he gets blown sideways it's like
one of the really cool moments Tom
Cruise might be a [ __ ] but he's
really good at his own stunts I don't
know nothing about him but I'll watch
him on the screen I actually don't know
that much but I try not to Nick learn
anything about any actors because it's
irrelevant yeah except for a little odds
are they're really bad people then if I
hear a Kevin Spacey is a bit tough -
yeah like if you're really bad people I
call it oh you're controlling this yeah
so this should seem familiar member you
go on the boss and everything this does
I don't know where I'm going yeah yeah
that way and you get Spritle do yourself
all shitty run you're slightly faster
crawl
I think the alley waits your left maybe
yeah so the controls in this game feel
awesome like it's it's a really good
blend between resonable sixes like way
too twitchy and then like resonant for
kind of isn't this like you can you
don't need the about-face like watch if
you press the opposite direction she'll
just do that like 360 or 180 turn oh let
me see yeah so she does it like and then
you can aim while moving it I don't know
I really like how this game feels
doesn't seem like I can 360 while I'm
aiming no sorry you can move in general
while aiming but like you can just do a
180 while you're moving
looks really good too it does look
really good okay
can I do this man oh god there's falling
out yes I like that that bus is there
like you don't need to go on it but it's
just like a pretty good reference like
yep yep we've won
that's the end of the game she walked
about I did it the penultimate nanny I
got two bullets still some bodies
wrapped up in here it's a lot actually
oh I got a true me actually you got a
trophy because I'm playing on your
account the most that's weird it's a
Claire specific one man uh-huh
this iconic Lobby key so you played a
bit of this during e3 yes should I not
have done that no I was good okay I
haven't really processed anything I just
saw I saw is the button and I hits the
button
I remember this yeah
I could just hear the lobby music from
the original game right now like even
though it well actually the music we're
hearing right now or like the sound are
hearing now is like a variation on it
but like it's still such a good like
faithful remake I guess I hope the game
is loud enough for the for obs
very I don't hear much but I don't know
if that's any indication yours is gonna
be lower for now yeah
saws do I still need this key okay
actually here's a helpful thing so see
there's a red checkmark at the bottom
right of the key icon yes
that means you can discard the item or
store it so like it's not like the
earlier names where I will say oh you've
used this all you can do you want to
discard it it'll show that checkmark and
you can just drop it that was one thing
they tell you like maybe like another
hour to into the game that I wish they
would show me up front like knowing the
original game was like I know I'm done
with the Spade key but
oh come on he could have done better
than that he got away
he's holding this tum tum though that
makes me nervous yeah so yeah II saw it
I think that's the door you just
unlocked I wonder do I need pucks is
this a no no not in this mode but you uh
you need a typewriter okay there's no
play autosave as those no the autosave
is also pretty generous I'm assuming if
it's like res evil 7 then you only need
pucks in the hardcore mode mm-hmm I have
yet to play it I'm really looking
forward to it
what do you think that means keep keep
out Oh actually one little detail that
so this game is like really good about
minor details as well when you are
reloading in the dark and they have a
flashlight pay attention to what they do
with the flashlight it's it's pretty
it's minor but it's pretty cool okay
like obviously don't force a reload but
lots of blood here
guess I need a fuse put your gun in it
what
I was joking well I thought you knew a
secret no
I like such a weird like deja vu kind of
like seeing all this [ __ ] remember
this from the demo - it was scary then
they do such a good job with their audio
design I don't have enough bullets how
many did you get last what do you have
like nine now yeah not even I think I've
six now I have eight also known as not
enough there's like that press briefing
room or something
aha oh look at that a little blood and
some gum
yay convenient um so that's it and I
just go back um I think you can go to
the left I think we got stuck here in
the e3 of yeah you can there's a little
button prompt to use your muscles
where
Oh God bathrooms are never good news in
horror games never even in real life you
never want them really yeah who needs
him
ooh I saw it just just checking my six
you know
Oh
feel I gotta breathe like can you hear
me not breathing
yeah I hold my breath when I play these
things this game is much creepier than
ever it's also like it you kind of saw
like it's pretty gory
it's definitely gory ER and that works
to me to like mess me up there's no way
they're all dead
no way um that door I needed a key third
this door oh god I think I remember this
part doesn't only happen like in most of
the trailers at this point so that's the
dude you saw in that video footage she's
like it's okay I got you
oh god Claire you [ __ ] it up she did
honestly looks like they had a fire door
too bad they didn't have a zombie door
this is my favorite sandwich here's how
you get there I think my wife is
cheating on me in this trap diagram um
there's obviously secrets here but I
don't know them
these look like code yes you can
reference these notes wherever you want
for the record okay well thank you check
his pulse
we'll never get home to me can they get
in through that door
there's another door wait stay on that
side sir
did you follow the form uh you be
check-in is that way reload you Butthead
is he stuck in there whoa where are we
going
yeah just run actually no that no come
on I don't have a key what am i doing
sorry behind you there's I [ __ ] but
there's two zombies there actually no
that door might be locked no you're
right I think run in this direction just
keep going the way you're going
oh you're knocking yeah I would
there you go oh god oh god go under the
door why so long why is it take so long
to something shoot it remember any other
guy's insides
oh yeah it's Marvin looks like your
party's been canceled
come on
are you one of them hmm she's like no
look nobody knows what caused this I
could do this I'm definitely not Zod
it's all about dexterity baby keep that
on just in case I'm not gonna be around
long as I find Chris we're out of here
you're really Chris's sister yeah why
should you find something he's on
vacation Europe I know he's uh he's at
the mansion that's great news we should
all take vacations from time to time
tell this always want to see Hungary
that's where my people are from hey we
should probably get you to a hospital
right yeah yeah I'm Hungarian yep don't
be ridiculous you're gonna need some
listen Claire save yourself so you can
see your brother
No
you probably need this now I'm not to
the match
and be careful
if you see one of those things
no matter who they were you can't
hesitate take them out if you can
that's what I did back there
she looks so good yeah oh yeah like read
this carefully because knives function
differently in the remake knife wears
down no you can see there's like a
health bar under it like a weapon
durability thing on the inventory why
does this happen I didn't like this in
breath of the wild and I don't like it
here remember in our remake what uh
remake the original remake you could use
it as like a defensive thing when they
grabbed you yeah you'll see a no one
when they grab you it you can do that
but it sticks in them so you have to
kill them and then pick it up afterwards
I like it a lot much more involved than
it used to be I'm hurt but I'm gonna
keep going for him he's looking at
YouTube he's key and peele guys crack me
up they are good um alright so now
should I save again I should probably
save considering I have pucks to spare
yeah if they gonna let me you know oh I
need to turn the volume down
so oh I can use it on this right yeah
there might be an herb upstairs right
now if you go up there first I have a
full spray that I found on the [ __ ]
oh so actually our pit might cover it up
a bit but press triangle you can see
your health at the bottom bless oh yeah
it does cover it up well not not a ton
like they'll see the color okay
so that's when we were talking the other
night I recommended putting them in the
bottom left so like yeah so press X and
then okay so it's on commercially we can
see it yeah we can see the color okay
but well we'll cover up the word but I
think people have watched this series
we'll know what the colors mean green
yellow and red yeah we discussed this
before when I was doing pips with you um
and I was like where should I put them
should I be on the left and you're on
the right like how do we do this now
that we're in oh we
yeah so this is the lion sorry I [ __ ]
up okay so you press X into that lion
well recipe I know you lion wheat bird
yeah okay
damn
[Laughter]
down down down
what's the combination to your luggage
nothing it's definitely not one two
three
[Laughter]
Wow the herbs are so big in this game
she's like a giant the inventories fall
[Laughter]
let's see
hope my mic isn't too loud I'm gonna
turn it down a little bit I can never
tell if it's a check the other side of
that balcony okay just for posterity
sake let me laugh and see if I pick the
mic
haha you don't
that was pretty annoying that it's my
spongebob impression your hand I never
nice I will convince
alright well it was worth the trek
mm-hmm and I I have a full heel so it
seems we need some sort of spade you're
in the hot seat girl do we ever discuss
this like the fact that obviously we
needed um there were crazy doors in the
first game because the man was a madman
but like why the [ __ ] is the
police-station like I'm crazy super
happy you brought that up because so it
is a giant Lorelei's there you go more
wise I would actually just probably use
that now
Lorelei's this police station used to be
an art museum with a lot of secret
passages in order to avoid like theft so
the underground tunnels were to avoid
like people hijacking their [ __ ] in this
remake they put like three extra notes
that really drive that home saying how
it used to be an art museum to make
people like believe that it's a real
place if that makes sense like they're
trying to make it make contextual sense
much more in the remake but yeah it used
to be an art museum a long time ago okay
I got it
and I guess that's the I don't know semi
explanation for the weird [ __ ] no
remember this hallway yes good
maybe they changed it up maybe they
didn't you know they did it looks like a
hospital
do it go you're in the hot seat girl
this sucks
hey it's Mikey 73 bird don't lift his
face don't lift his face don't lift his
face I would that's tiny watch yes did
that pipe go through the back of his
head and through his mouth yeah it's
like um
remember res equals seven that happened
to the dude in the basement at the
beginning yes God that game is really
good Oh is there like a lock for this
window feel like I've forgotten
importance they've added something but I
won't you'll see it's pretty cool
mechanic actually
oh my god oh my god oh my god again what
I was kidding
sorry it's tense enough look at that
cross crucifix oh yeah that's
unnecessary lays there door to your
right or is that there out around the
corner okay sorry sorry yeah it's around
the corner [ __ ] with me no no no
never the briefing room with Olivia
I couldn't member who is this part of
the hallway are around the corner no
[ __ ] getting that grief get in it get in
the thing come in can they come through
this door I think so they cannot go in
the damn Hall she's like you tell me oh
[ __ ] I keep missing Jesus thank you
oh so you probably did not notice it but
when you reload with a flashlight oh my
god flashlight they like tuck the
flashlight under their chin like a phone
while they reload it's pretty cool
nicely
suck my chin when did that happen are
you in caution though yes with the
flashlight oh no she doesn't so Leon
does but she doesn't that's pretty cool
okay nevermind so Leon like because he
has to pull a magazine out of his belt
he does that he like tucks endures chin
dude come on caution already um yeah
this game is not very forgiving she's
well and it was a floor bite too
normally like they're cooler about that
oh yeah usually those are like an
instant kill so there are some sound
effects that come through my oh yeah
like the keys are through your dick Don
locking is right I'll go through my mic
on accident that's alright it's am I
done here let me check search all the
crannies you know you've learned well
over how many seasons 9 what was the
last episode we did Brazzaville 0 finale
yeah we did it no didn't we do
revelations or whatever oh [ __ ] that's
right Jesus
we still have Revelations to to do at
some point I know isn't that co-op
though yes can we do it online co-op
yeah
then technically it should work with
this setup yeah this game is better from
what I played though by far Oh balls
you could try just knifing him okay so
from what I can tell the durability of
the knife does not pertain to when
you're actually using it like this it
only does
it's only the counter-attack defensive
things like this should not wear it down
I like how she's actually sneaking okay
nice nice give me a trophy as well is he
dead yeah you got trophy for killing him
listen I was [ __ ] her attacked from
the floor yeah [ __ ] my knife is broken
oh wait oh [ __ ] I was completely wrong
press triangle oh so that does decrease
the durability but not as much so if you
do wanted like the counter-attack things
it'll actually go down like a third wow
I mean that was a fifth that was a lot
yeah but still that was I think worth
the bullets you saved
um all right what am i doing that's
super helpful as far as items you've
seen like if you go back to the main
hall you can see items and [ __ ] like
there's a first-aid spray there in the
hallway that sorry I'm like a fuse there
I think you're still kind of exploring
there's a couple doors you can go
through right here you're near the
weapons Locker or safety deposit room
sorry this should look familiar
balls I hate this room yeah this is
where you first see Marvin in the
original game yes ray says the park
hassle thing nice you have a pretty
decent out of bullets yeah you saved
like five last dude
so this is like a resonable 7 thing so
gunpowder is handgun ammo gunpowder and
high-grade gunpowder is acid and then
submachine right rounds you're [ __ ]
alive aren't you
oh that is dick ooh nice
thank you wait how much did that yeah
that's not bad I think the other one was
worse cuz I continued to stab him yeah
wonder if it's like Dark Souls 1 & 2 or
it actually degrades the weapon or if
it's like 3 where you have to be hitting
them I bet you I'm not gonna test it cuz
I don't want to but I bet you if I don't
know if you hit the wall it definitely
[ __ ] it up I hit the wall it would [ __ ]
it up yeah
your mission is unlock your desk Marvin
Branagh so [ __ ] cheesy the initials
of our first names and put the letters
in in order of our desks there are two
locks one on each side of your desk make
sure to get them both basically your
first task is to remember your fellow
officers names but you figured that out
right good luck Leon
okay so do I need to know his whole name
like what's Leone Kennedy's middle
initial no it's he was saying you need
to know your fellow officers first names
it's the order of their names according
to the desks in the room ah so I don't
interestingly enough s and Liana's
kennedy does not stand for anything like
I use the CSS grant weird little piece
of trivia it is weird
yeah so the events of resin will one
take place on my birthday or at least
like one one day of it so that was
Elliott I'm guess I'm confused is this
how we do it it's the first letter of
each of their first names so this is
Elliott no no there's one to the left of
him and that's David yeah so something
Eady
um Oh Neil so Ned Neil yeah code will be
a D and E D for the left side the other
one
yeah there's two padlocks no like left
padlock would be yes I see yeah that's
why I can't be a cop um I broke in ah
Marvin Rita so when I first played this
I did not kill him before I did this and
I was looking for the nametag and he's
scared the [ __ ] out of me
he what's your name soldier
um
is it on his thing George MRT so his
name was George Scott in the letter
Marvin said don't be surprised if Scott
makes it hard for you I think he was
just saying he's a dick but also like
it's kind of a joke because he's a
zombie waiting in his own desk
ooh so that's for a different gun is
that mad just no that's for your gun
it's a faster reload if you combine it
with my gun yeah
then yeah
I'm a customizer okay so here's the
weird thing I don't think these trophies
were lives when I played the game two
days ago
uh-uh so I'm saying you're doing stuff
that I've done already did you hear that
yeah was it a dog no oh man you're
already scared of dogs huh I'm always
scared of dogs when I'm not
I [ __ ] hate dogs in this game I have
to preface it with in this game because
I love dogs but I hate dogs in this game
let's go say you haven't gone to the
office yet oh [ __ ] I missed I missed
again
his head is so wobble I know oh you do
reload faster now that's helpful
you think this is George [ __ ]
oh Jesus [ __ ]
Oh that'd get him I hope so he's prop oh
my god he'd like fell into y'all's like
the Blaz person tricked me you could a
knife em just to be sure if you want I'd
rather use no waste a little bit of the
nice durability than a bullet
oh [ __ ]
they keep tricking me nice doesn't it
feel great how they like react to
getting shot though like as opposed to
resonable six like a polar opposite yes
seven did it really well too but
okay I need to know the combination of
that lock was it on the piece of paper
that I was reading or something no there
was another room yeah through there that
you didn't go through yet in here I mean
you have [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Skype just
crashed this is going to happen every
once in a while guys sorry hopefully I
can fix this
look how stupid he looks when there's
nothing there
cuz I'm not sure if it's him or me
sometimes
um just messaging him I'm also not sure
if it was him or me
hi hi my skype crashed again I'm sorry
I'll just edit it out we mean you can
but I would also say this is just the
way things are sometimes sometimes I
don't think people will care that much
sometimes sky pull crash I just paused
the game it didn't take very long uh
record Skype is hit or miss we tinkered
around with some different ideas but
skypes the best option for us right now
so okay well well if it's not terrible
we'll just roll with it but otherwise oh
I don't know I don't know but yeah
there's another that safety-deposit film
do you have oh [ __ ] yeah let him it's
the integer take your hat off in the
presence of a woman buddy oh I got him
some matters there's no way that guy's
dead like I know it and you know it and
he knows it his arms gone doesn't mean
[ __ ]
oh man
oh [ __ ]
oh man his skull just disappeared don't
let the door hit you with a Lord split
you oh yeah okay he's really [ __ ] up
yeah he's dead now okay so over all
right yeah there okay so you'll probably
remember that this is where our demo and
the bonus episode ended yeah I remember
seeing this stuff so that too and the
three are missing and everything but you
can go kind of look around the locker
and see what you want to open so sneaky
gunpowder a knife but how can I do
without the numbers do you find the keys
yeah you can't open those - yeah that's
really good - that's a hip house that
increases your inventory size who needs
1:09 that and the ones here right 106
and 109 okay
you might as well just open a 109 while
you're still here
you're doing pretty well on em I think
do you think I don't think so
I don't think you'd miss much at all
maybe earlier on but you then
I'm almost my inventory is almost full
all right so that's it for this room
right for now yeah
like there's a hallway laughs there's a
hallway to the left
this hole this pipe yeah this might look
familiar to you this is where a save
room is this actually might be a good
place to end episode 1 it's been like an
hour and there's also a save room coming
up yeah so you see you got a way where
are you oh yeah so it's the dark room
you could you could check that on camera
film you just picked up if you want to
before you save whoa I sorry in the dark
room commemorative god every is every
roll of film commemorative god damn oh
okay
so see those boards right there that is
you can use those on the windows to
block people from coming in they're
coming in right now yeah yeah I can't
take them well there's a safe room right
next to you you could deposit a couple
things and then go block off that window
[ __ ] that was my shirt told you put them
adalian in the thing there's the
medallion yeah you have it in your
inventory you got it from the lion thing
I would say store the first-aid spray
keep the film cuz you're gonna use it in
literally the room right next to you and
you should be good like I'd say yeah use
the film and that might be a good place
to save it
[Music]
it's just a creepy guy yeah that's it
it's just a creepy guy yeah what's that
Renard what that's crazy yeah I can bind
that with a green probably well I don't
know with you um well you want to save
it there and call that the first episode
yeah that sounds great
there's a typewriter right there I think
okay oh gosh I'm on Kosh that dank dank
it's some dinky dink well I think I did
pretty good for our first attempt I
guess I'll have to at the recording to
make sure it works um besides Skype
crashing that one time oh [ __ ] sorry I
mean to do that I meant it there's David
David's art again yeah and it's not all
of it I think I can show more of it hold
on it's all these hands look those are
all those are all Knievel fans hands
actually through a discord channel we
sent photos actually I think : go back
down to the hands one of those is mine
oh the umbrella moon that's good oh I
didn't notice the umbrella alone are all
secret um my hand is the fat one okay
wait where I can't see your mouse the
mine is the one that's like fifth from
the left it's like making a C yeah I see
it doesn't matter um it's the fat one
sans I've huge hands they're manly now
just kidding I have small hands okay
cool but yeah I have a I have a little
screen specifically for art so when art
is finished on our discord channel I'll
share it and we can take a look at it at
the end of every episode cool yeah you
got mine you got the side profile right
my head looks like an anvil do head to
the side yeah no profile
sweet well thank you David
and thanks Mary for me not I'm gonna go
home and sleep but catch up next time
yeah this has been more a cash and Mikko
Morty
here back at it again with the real
stuff yeah back at it um yes
we'll be back every Saturday as much as
time permits that's right as always
but uh thanks i right for joining if you
haven't go catch up on other Knievel's
in the week but until we publish our
next episode we might be publishing more
than one in like throughout we won't
since this game is like timely and
relevant we might be publishing more
episodes I don't want to promise
anything yeah it's great to be messed up
to like technical issues right now
because I'm waiting on a piece of
hardware to make this a little more
efficient for us but we'll see um thank
you guys for watching we'll be back
we'll be back again you think that went
pretty well I just pooped I'm still
recording yeah what